before the Spanish conquest and before
the Inca Empire one group created the
most important South American
civilization at the time the chimú the
chimú civilization lasted almost half a
millennium from the Year 1000 to around
1470 AD at its height the kingdom
spanned the region between the southern
border of Ecuador and the Peruvian
capital of Lima much of the chimú
success had to do with their engineering
capabilities and artistry the chimú were
able to construct massive structures
particularly in the wealthy capital city
of chan chan thousands of Adobe
structures such as palaces and temples
were up to hundreds of feet long and
some of those buildings had walls about
30 feet high the chimú also developed a
signature artistic style craftsmen
excelled at producing luxury textiles
and elaborate metal works they also
created ceramics that were distinctly
chimú and often reflected aspects of
their coastal lifestyle such as fish
otters and sea birds
despite advancements in art and
engineering the chimú civilization
eventually fell by around 1470 AD they
were conquered by the next great Andean
civilization the Inca
[Music]
centuries later however the chimú
culture and lives on in 1986 Chan Chan
was designated a UNESCO World Heritage
Site helping preserve the legacy of this
ancient culture for many more years to
come
[Music]
[Music]